this is a story of somebody who hired
either a an incompetent lawyer or B ran
with a really bad strategy for their
defense that's right sisters this ain't
our fight this one ain't one of ours sit
this one out sisters you said the same
thing with Pirates of the Caribbean you
said the same thing I said they're going
to call back Johnny and they called back
Johnny you said no they didn't they
didn't call him back Jonathan Majors a
lot of folks wanted us to cover it I did
some readings on it if you're aren aware
who Jonathan major is a um I've never
seen any of his movies so I didn't know
who he was for a long time I have uh but
essentially this guy was like the face
of the MCU apparently yeah he got
embroiled in some
domestic uh ended up costing him
everything went to trial and just a few
days ago he was found guilty on two of
the four Chargers now a lot of people
feel some type of way some people saw
the released footage of Jonathan major
running away from his girlfriend uh
which I think is worth watching bcks cuz
that way she chased him down in heels
like a Terminator that was not that was
not running away that was a whole ass
Marathon this was a chase you see in
movies where they running he be jumping
over fences and stuff like that and
you're like where are they going how
long are they running I can't run for
that long they've been running for that
long so this is them in the car
allegedly they're essentially fighting
over his phone because she claims she
saw Tech from other woman so she took
she his phone and he's trying to put him
like took the phone back
anyways so it's them fighting and then
you see him walking away he Yanks her
off tells her get away from me and he
starts hi tailing it and he pushes her
off and he runs and she chases him God
damn and she chasing and he she give me
that phone back who's that [__] I
thought I was supposed to be your
Michelle
Obama is this what Barack is do doing to
his girl and she running she not giving
up blocks bro listen if people fought
for their marriage the way she's chasing
after him I think nobody would get
divorced she see uncommon traffic she
said I love you [__] she's said the N
word is that in the audio no but I just
want to believe she did jeez turning the
corner hey there's some little rental
bikes you know what I'm saying another
block oh wait there's more the video
keeps going yeah it's long it's long She
chased him it's very long She chased him
and this is where a lot of the
contention comes into play cuz people
see that video and they're like clearly
this man is not the aggressor why was he
found
guilty and let's read some of the
charges according to the criminal
complaint Majors hit jabari's face
Twisted her arm and fractured her finger
during a fight in a chauffeur car that's
the video that we saw uh she provided
video evidence or picture evidence you
can see some of the wounds behind her
ear you can see the bruising to her
fingers and so they're saying the
evidence presented throughout this trial
Illustrated a cycle of psychological and
emotional and escalating patterns of
coercion far too common across many
intimate partner violence cases we see
in every day said Alvin Bragg in his in
a statement today a jury determined that
that pattern of abuse and cotion
culminated with Mr major assaulting and
harassing his girlfriend now it's a bit
of a lad to think it's not really what
the charges say but that's what the
lawyer is going to say cuz he wants to
make it seem like the biggest win right
cuz prosecutors got to do that whenever
so he was found not guilty assault in
the third degree injury intentional he
was found not guilty of it being
intentional and he was found not guilty
of aggravated harassment second degree
intentional okay what he was found
guilty of was physical injury Reckless
and harassment the second degree
um intentional so the difference between
aggravated harassment and harassment is
basically like one of them is a
misdemeanor which means like you're just
getting a fine versus one's actual
criminal record and it'll stay there so
aggravated harassment would be much more
serious than um harassment in the second
degree the difference between the
intentional result in the third degree
versus Reckless is sometimes you can
just engage in Behavior that's seen as
Reckless and hurt somebody but they
don't think it's premeditated or with
intention to hurt the other person so
for example um let's say you bump into
somebody while you're running down the
street and you hurt them severely as
you're running you push right through
them that could be seen depending on
like the person being old and different
things like that and how you should have
known better than to just run through
the street and bulldo over people like
that that could be seen as Reckless
that's what he was found guilty of so it
doesn't really follow with the statement
of the lawyer who says like oh well the
jury found that there was a pattern and
coercion all stuff they're just saying
in the heat of a moment and what is
essentially a very toxic relationship
between two people uh he engaged in
Reckless injury now I'll let you go
first what do you think about everything
that you've heard so far oh just to be
clear too it did cost him his job the
MCU fired him right afterwards or Disney
did uh it's cost him all his acting gigs
all of his commercials so this dude was
the rising star everybody's looking out
for him and now his career is pretty
much over dead in the water as of right
now so as a consequence he suffered yeah
I I don't think he did it I just think
he's got bad lawyers um you think yeah
um they were essentially trying to paint
him as like some good man who wouldn't
do this kind of stuff
and I'm like if you just gone the
self-defense ride I don't think you
would have lost I don't know why he was
going through this rout like nothing
ever happened and like then you see the
pictures like clearly she got hurt and
there was a tussle there's no doubt
about that you can see it on camera so
you know going that route is so stupid
to me it's like if somebody takes your
possession by law you're allowed to use
Force to get it back now it has to be
proportionate but grabbing someone and
pushing them away as you're grabbing
back your phone 100% it doesn't change
because that person is your girlfriend
it doesn't change because that person is
your wife if they grabb something from
you you're allowed to physically grab
them and push them off as you grab your
stuff The Reckless thing it's hard for
even I'm the jury to find him not guilty
of that because he clearly did hurt her
yeah and if you're not even going to
make the affirmative defense of like
well she had my possession and I was
taken a then I can't give you the not
guilty verdict because you did hurt her
you did you you don't have an
explanation for why you're claiming it
didn't happen but we can see the video
and we can see the pictures so you
clearly did hurt her you know if it's
like this you're running down the street
M okay you run into an old woman
recklessly and then they ask you
afterwards after she gets injured why
did you do that and you're like I never
did that I can see you hurt the person
but if you say no there was a shooting
down the block and I was running away
then the motive actually changes it so
it's the same injury same circumstances
it becomes acceptable because there's a
reason why you bolting it down the
street he didn't provide I'm still going
to be guilty of exactly he didn't
provide a good reason for why and I'm
just like bro just say self-defense yeah
maybe from a PR standpoint it won't look
like the best thing to your future
career but now you have a guilty charge
on something you shouldn't have a guilty
charge cuz if you think about it right
the law doesn't change because the other
person's your partner it doesn't change
because the other person is small
provided the injuries are proportionate
now if you'd have given her two black
eyes and stomped out one of her legs and
like okay obviously that's not
proportional then then you you're much
more severe injuries but the injuries
were very consistent with people tusting
over a phone and then with the video
evidence of him running away and him
basically saying listen this girl was
trying to invade my privacy whatever the
[__] it might be and I need to get away
from her because she's taking my stuff
that's a a defense that makes more sense
to me but just going there like oh he's
a good man he would never do this she
was actually the abuser that's stupid to
me I think the thing that he was saying
that he didn't do was the the the verbal
and the the C and stuff like that
because when he was saying one evidence
that they showed was the speech that he
was giving her it's like yo listen I'm
I'm I'm being great I'm doing great
stuff I I don't want you to come home
and being drunk like that like Michelle
Obama want to do this and started naming
up a whole bunch of people you know pett
man all that people all all those people
it's like no I did not yell at her which
in the in the in this in the evidence I
don't see that he was yelling he was
talking to his wife yeah was he scolding
her his wife his girl it's Sor sorry
yeah sorry I just don't want you to give
the wife treatment to a girlfriend it's
different it's different until you put a
ring until you put a ring on it don't be
using certain terms cuz then you going
to expect wife treatment from a
girlfriend he talking about be my brush
did he put a ring on it I didn't think
so Michelle is a
wife
ter yeah but if she was Michelle
before in order to for you to proceed to
be your wife you got to be you got to be
a wife before you got to be the material
before that's what you think I heard
Barack married her right away anyways
that's decides the point yeah can we
proceed with the girlfriend we can't
proceed with her not the wife all right
I'll proceed with the girlfriend go for
it this
is so coing his girlfriend like oh we're
not supposed to do that if I'm
disappointed and if my my girl is cold
than me is because she wants me to do
better doesn't mean that she's mad at me
or doesn't mean not necess mad but it
doesn't mean that she doesn't love me or
she's trying to be toxic or whatever
what not like I think that narrative was
thrown out there to be like but I don't
think they didn't find him guilty of
that I'm I'm not saying that but I what
I'm saying is the I did not do thing was
towards that I think not I I didn't he
didn't say I didn't no he said he never
put hands on her he said he never hurt
her how is that your defense when
there's clear physical evidence of the
injuries and the reason why he did that
you want to know real the real reason
why he did that is because he wanted to
keep all of his jobs it was really
important I suspect I don't actually
know this I suspect because they wanted
the good PR he had to go with I did
nothing and the courts are going to
prove it that's but he can't it it
didn't work out in court and now we
backfired cuz now he got a criminal
record and now the public thinks he
really beat her versus at least if he
said try to snatch my phone and we got
into a tussle it still sounds terrible
from a PR standpoint right because like
you said it's a woman who's smaller all
that stuff and you're still going to
lose your job but now you have a
criminal record like what you want me to
say I don't know I I just thought that
was a dumb part to me do I think I think
this is a mutually bad relationships for
both parties okay and you're seeing her
run after him in the streets doing all
this stuff you can clearly see she not
all up there either these are two people
who were saying weird stuff and doing
weird stuff to each other um was it like
they was beating on each other it
doesn't look like it they don't really
have physical evidence of that to that
degree you don't have to get to that
degree for it to be toxic and bad yeah
yeah but you know that video is pretty
much what sealed the deal for him plus
the physical evidence I just think the
his lawyers did a bad job so all the
people saying this is a Mis charage of
Justice I don't think so you think
you're going to go to I don't think it's
a miscar of J I just think this is bad
lawyers you think it's going to they
always appeal they always appeal does it
really matter like most people who
appeal like 95% of them don't get
anywhere with it so little appe appeal
but like you missed you missed the
chance and now even if you appeal and
you succeed like people are still going
to say you were found guilty so I don't
know um that's what I thought watching
everybody loses what do you think it's
very unfortunate uh then again one thing
that we have to note is that um the uh
the jury was not 100% on everything like
what I mean by that it was like a you
know when you fight and there's a split
decision that's what it was not
everybody was um was agreeing with all
those things that's why we have like
kind a kind of a split with the with the
with the decision of the jury the jury
was not all of them were not agreeing
with yeah he did that or that was clear
or anything like that people was like
yes no so it came to that conclusion
anyways there's always something that
it's weird to me whenever there's people
in the public like that and it goes out
in the open and then everything is known
I understand why it's done but it's it's
just there's something that is very off
about it's like you want you really want
to hurt the person more than just
getting reparation or or or for what
happened or anything like that you know
you wouldn't necessarily want to no he
did something bad to me but you want
it's like you want to hurt his whole
career and that's something that's kind
of weird for me I understand where why
why it's happening but it it's I don't
know why it hurts me that it hurts me a
bit I don't know why I'm like I don't
know why why is that happening like that
should we do should we do that I ask
myself the question of like why is it so
so public but then again I understand
it's Hollywood people want to know and
people will know and it's something that
is relevant um to some people you know
every time there's a there's a there's a
problem with like stars everybody has to
know when it's blown it's in the news
news ooh this is what happened It's Kind
the re it really sounds like a revenge
or something like that you know to me
I'm I feel uneasy with that part but
it's something that that has nothing to
do with one or the other it's always
going to be like that yeah I always feel
like if it was normal people of course
it wouldn't be in the news that bad
necessarily you know but because it's
known yeah let's affect his old ass
career which goes back to the question
of should we separate a person's
personal life and his art no there's no
reason to CU they use their personal
life to promote themselves they use
their relationships to promote their
brands they use a lot of their stuff and
the truth
is the public cares about the kind of
people they support so they don't want
to see actors who have criminal
histories of stealing or murdering or
they probably don't want to necessarily
watch movies with those people so it's
relevant to the audiences and it's
relevant to the pr like you know
marketing of a movie is just as
important as a movie itself often times
but that thing was so so gray and not
clear and there was a lot of things and
a lot of a lot of elements that we're
not seeing as we're not sitting in court
and seeing all the evidence so basing
oursel on that is very great like
there's a lot of things that are not
showing in the news and even if you're
watching the news it's it's it's
depending of which news Outlet you're
watching somewhere saying oh he's guilty
and I'm like yeah no it's not exactly
what the [__] is going on uh and and
other Outlet we're we're trying to say
hey you know what let's put a little
little a little but a little bit of
water in our wine and just simmer it
down and see let me let let us explain
to you what what really happens
so I understand that the people want to
want to the people want to to know
what's happening and stuff like that I
understand all that but it's it's
still it's so it was great it was really
great I feel like there's a lot of
things that were missing for us to be
able to to be like no I don't like him
because he he beats woman or even say to
the girl nah she he was saying he was
being abusive or she was lying there's a
lot of elements that were missing we're
not in court and it's it's it's a weird
one for me to be like yeah no he did
that or he didn't I can't judge someone
like that I was not in court this is a
story of somebody who hired either a an
incompetent lawyer or B ran with a
really bad strategy for their defense H
that's what this is really about cuz he
had reasonable out well sometimes it's
not the lawyer sometimes that's what
what the client wants sometimes the
lawyer says I think our best route is
this and the client is like nah I'm
paying you I didn't do [__] so if you're
going to go up there and say that I did
this [__] you're going to get fired
that's said bad strategy either A or B
that's sometimes a lawyer the lawyer the
lawyer doesn't necessarily take the
range and depending on what kind of
lawyer you got whatever they don't
necessarily take the Reign they're like
listen that's what the CL there's some
lawyers like they're they're going to be
like hey that's what the client wants
that's what the client's going to get I
don't want to do that but that's what
you want and you're going to be happy
and at the end of the day Lord can go
hey hey hey we went your way uhhuh and
it turned out the way that I said that
it could possibly turn out I did my job
pay up sucker you know what I mean so
I'm not necessarily going to yeah I I
because I know that I understand why you
giving the two the two um the two
options
I'm I'm not in the room so I don't know
what but I couldn't believe it when they
just didn't go that route you know but I
I also think her going public I'm not
even mad at her for going public because
this stuff got out right it gets out
people start spinning narratives if not
me not only did I find out you cheating
on me you making me look stupid but now
you trying to make me oh no I'm telling
everybody
everything this man beat me he gasl me
he stonewalled me he was a bad boyfriend
who emotionally abused me and then he
tried to take his phone back cuz he was
cheating with another woman and guess
what he doing to her he using her too
yeah Jonathan miners likes kids miners
yeah he does I just in everything you
going to cheat on me and make me look
stupid not today [__] even though I'm
white I like saying it okay yeah oh yeah
I I would have gone public with that
[__] too you like the idea that she said
[__] yeah I think she did do I have any
proof of that absolutely not
yeah you can't go to but I talked to a
lot of my black sisters and they don't
like Jonathan major once they find out
his girl was white and they say she says
me so I trust
them fighter power that's right sisters
this ain't our fight this one ain't one
of ours sit this one out sisters I see
you in the comment section I see you
it's okay I respect
it far as his career goes like is it sad
and unfortunate yeah I think I don't
think it's the end of this of his career
I think it's going to
last a six months to a year oh no no no
you think so yeah we taking bets on this
you said the same thing with Pirates of
the Caribbean you said the same thing I
said they're going to call back Johnny
and they call back Johnny you said you
no they didn't they didn't call him back
it's not even happening that's just a
rumor that came up but that never even
happened and has Johnny Depp been in any
major
movies let me check I know he did some
lowbudget stuff and shout out to Johnny
I hope his career comes back but to my
knowledge he hasn't done anything let me
see Johnny Depp movies so the last movie
he did is in 2023 which is the the the
bud the one I was telling you about this
thing was like [__] yeah there's
nothing he not doing
[__] his career's over oh what has he
done since there's no way that we're
going to reboot him his name has too
much stuff going on for them I think
it's just rumors that people put out
because they want clicks there's no
there's no proof now look if he does
make a comeback maybe but how how long
has it been since then so we're still
going to see so so how long has it been
since then it's been what over a year
and a half now oh we didn't bet any time
frame we said the pirate caran thing all
right we'll find out we'll see we'll see
maybe maybe in a decade you never know
but who a lot of these people have even
if they beat the case because the shit's
so public they don't want to touch it
cuz it's like Crypton to them so you
think he's going to be back in 6 months
with a guilty verdict what what what
kind of movie well Disney's not bringing
him back so who will Tyler Perry might
hire him maybe if you want to be the
next media he can be the big girl now
what media's
daughter media's daughter would be good
yeah it's over it's over it's over it's
over he was that guy he will never ever
come close to sniffing that [__]
again he will never come close to I put
my money on it my life savings on it how
much I put 100K on it there's no way
he's ever sniffing any of that [__]
again it's not a not a not a roll he got
a guilty verdict my [__] not a role not
a role no he might show up in some Ricky
dick movie I'm talking about Majors for
majers that's not happening you think
he's going to come back to doing that
with a guilty verdict of
domestic sorry Reckless aggravated hope
still towards the woman every interview
that [__] coming up you think he's
coming back with that how much do you
think we've evolved that Society where
he come back
with maybe that's the fact that we
haven't evolved that he's going to come
back not the fact that we evolved it's
the fact that we haven't evolved that
he's going to that he's going to come
back I'm curious okay outside of the
dudes in the in in the past like Sean
Conor give me examples of dudes who got
charged with beating their wives and
made a career comeback and it was public
like this he didn't get Char by of
beating his wife or beating sorry his
girlfriend Reckless aggravated sorry
sorry beating his girl beating his girl
don't don't give give the wife treatment
you right my sorry sister sorry don't
give the wife treatment to a so beat his
girl to a hoopa okay so yes he beat his
girl that's that's what the charger say
doesn't matter what reality is it's on
the guilty verdict and it's on camera
and it looks terrible so oh you got
freed of
that he didn't beat no he no it's guilty
there's a tussle and he heard her in the
process he didn't beat her is that what
you're going to say in press conferences
and every interview when yeah yeah ain't
no movie studio bringing you back ain't
no movie studio I I you know what leave
a comment below tell me tell me why you
think I'm wrong about him making a
comeback and who you see make a comeback
from stuff like this that was just
publicized I'll be curious I can't think
of one person who's made a comeback
there's some nerds out there that
wouldn't know that
[__] sure I'm just thinking about all
the public cases I've seen till now
nerds unite no and it's just like these
people don't need they don't come back
you don't you're not you're not going to
ask your ner friend no let us know what
you guys think in the comments I'm
curious ask the ask ask the Discord yeah
yeah Discord there's also a Reddit would
you see the side of your forehead